I saw uh ad said something because you
had Snoopy badass on yeah who uh he
wants special treatment because uh it's
gonna be badass had a video where he
basically said that like and this was a
long time ago because I I did an
interview with Snoopy like two years ago
and A.D wasn't there or anything and
like Snoop and Snoopy had a video where
he basically said that ad was blocking
him from going on no jumper and that ad
is just a hater because you know
Snoopy's the real king of Compton or
whatever the [__] he said so when I had
Snoopy on the other day I asked him what
was up with that video are you saying
that you would [__] ad up or whatever
and I guess you know A.D like last night
did this whole song and dance acting
like the victim acting like oh that's so
[__] up that I would ask this dude
about him
um so just for the record I am one of
the greatest hip-hop podcasters to ever
live and if you think that I'm gonna
have a [__] on the show and not
ask him about the beef that he
previously had with someone who was a
host on the channel
a you're not paying attention to what
I've been doing for all these years
because that is 100 what I do if I have
an interview with a rapper that hates
bootleg Kev tomorrow I'm gonna probably
make it clear in the course of the
interview like I [__] would be like Kev
but I'm gonna say so why are you like
cup yeah that's normal that's what
everybody does AD like I don't know why
he like thinks he needs like special
treatment but I think the reality is is
that he probably isn't even actually
bothered by what I said in the interview
with Snoopy badass he just does like
four streams a week and he needs topics
and he needs stuff to talk about and so
that probably seemed like something that
would be good click bait right and
that's not like people just you see
people become this weird version of
themselves and they start faking fights
and they start faking beefs and they
start you know creating beefs out of
nothing or whatever and it's like
I don't know like I saw like a two
minute clip of his stream in the Reddit
and I just didn't even I didn't even
think about responding it just seems so
I was gonna say I think he said that you
guys were like cordial you've got some
text conversations since then and
everything but like okay why do we have
a text conversation when I was in
Florence about to get married is because
his cousin came on one of the November
panels
and then A.D did a whole stream talking
about you know if if I'm not [__]
with Adam then you or if you're my
cousin you shouldn't go on no jumper or
whatever and I hit him up I send them
like you know a couple of texts just
being like bro I didn't know you had a
problem with this [__] guy like like
what do you like but again it's like
he needed some click bait he needed
something to talk about that week so you
see how A.D even being who he is he just
is I don't know it's like weird like oh
you could have just texted me and said
like why'd you interview my cousin
instead you do a three hour live stream
about it and you know that but that's
why I kind of feel bad for these guys
because it's like they they feel like
they have to talk about me to get views
and to get people to pay attention
because that's
all of their most viral content has just
been talking well I think Lush said that
I think Lush is like this is what y'all
want so I'm gonna keep doing it Lush did
a whole video swearing that he wasn't
going to talk about me anymore and
thanking me for the positive impact on
his career and everything and then he
interviews somebody else that I don't
[__] with and he said like hey I really
tried to stop talking about November but
this is what y'all want but you guys
don't watch my [__] unless I talk about
no jumper so I'm talking about no jumper
now the difference between Lush talking
about a no jumper and not talking about
November is he'll get like a thousand
views on an average stream and then
he'll talk about his jumper and I'll get
like ten thousand
Okay so
yes that is a 10x multiplier but still
you're a grown ass man getting 10 000
views on your live stream have you guys
chatted at all I mean he tries to hit me
up and stuff and it's like bro I just
don't [__] with you because I I like you
know I had him on and uh he went on he
went off on me on some [__] podcast
and then I ended up bringing him on and
we're you know we're cool because I
think I caught I I called him some [__]
when you and I because I I never was
like a fan of him on the channel but
when I met him I was like oh he seems
like a really genuinely like like nice
dude and and with him it's like it just
reminds me like do not operate your
business like a [__] charity project
because he was somebody that was just so
obviously [__] and like I put him on
the channel because it was like I
thought that that was kind of like an
interesting narrative like look at this
guy he's an ex-junkie he's [__]
addicted to banging prostitutes on fig
he's just got like a clearly got a few
screws loose he's chasing this battle
rap dream but then you know like we
brought him on the channel and it's just
like everybody on the channel was just
viciously clowning him all the time and
I was the one telling people I was the
one sitting down with Almighty suspect
and saying like suspect you got to go
easy on Lush you can't just like be this
mean to him because I remember there was
like a freestyle thing with a lush
wrapped and suspect was laughing so hard
like falling out of his chair and it was
so funny and I'm over here I'm the one
looking out for lunch saying suspect you
can't treat them like that like suspect
you got to be nicer to him whatever
t-rell was [__] [__] on him left
and right he [__] hated him and I'm
kind of trying to like you know navigate
that and and you know like why was I
going out of my way to help this guy I
never did one bad thing to this guy and
then of course all of his streams are
about me because I'm the only successful
person that he's ever been around in his
entire life I'm the only famous person
that he's ever been associated with so
he has to talk about me or else
nothing's ever going to move my
challenge to all of those guys and I've
said this before is
get a million views
have an opinion have a thought are you
talking about on a specific video make a
video that gets a million views have a
thought have an opinion do something
the stipulations are
you can't get a million views talking
about me that's not going to do it
there's not a million people who care
that much about any of these exos
talking about me or you know uh get an
interview talk to somebody who's like
really interesting and get a million
views that's my challenge to every
single one of them well I think you will
have proven to me that you successfully
left the nest when you get a million
views because I could tell you that last
month I got 50 million views on my
YouTube channel and this is like people
talk about a sinking ship all of these
channels combined are maybe 10 of the
views that I get in a month
and I'm a sinking ship this is what
these people actually want you to
believe it's [__] narrative they
were never mistreated while they were on
the channel I was always transparent
about pay I was always like very uh you
know open to having discussions about
what the future of the channel was going
to be so that that is the one thing that
really bothers me is just this [__]
victim narrative that was painted on the
way out but I don't think the people are
falling for it anymore I you know the
channel is doing way way better we're
crushing it right now
um and I have tons more great ideas and
at the end of the day
you need money to go to war and I got a
lot of it and I I can't I mean I don't
think they want to I mean I I would hate
to see like a wart I mean obviously to
me it's like there's a scoreboard right
and I'm way up even though people tried
to paint me as if I was way down yeah I
mean well but I do think it's important
to acknowledge like
community and and and back on fig are
are successful they're not maybe there
is a jumper successful but thank you I
think you've you have a head start you
know true you've been and I'm a goat I
mean look yeah of course you're you have
some of the most iconic interviews of
all time listen I think you got to look
at it as like through the scope of like
these guys just started these channels
so it's like you know but they need to
get a million views you know have you
watched uh fig Community world no no you
never well I've seen some clips here
yeah
yeah I just think that like they're
building something that they're you know
and I just wish that there was less like
like I don't I didn't like the way the
whole split happen you know what I'm
saying
um yeah it was [__] but I think that
uh
you know both things can be true
they're successful
maybe not as successful as you but again
you have a head start but they're doing
I'm sure they're making much more money
for their families for themselves then
would you acknowledge that that they're
probably making more money now than they
were making with no jumper hell no you
don't think so no no no no no okay so I
I'm not in the business so I just know
that they have sponsors they got you
know they got their own sponsor money
coming in like I don't know I just I
just feel like they're probably and they
might be okay even if it's even if
they're making 75 of what they were
making with you oh hell no you don't
think so no I mean I listen a lot of
people talk to me a lot of people tell
me things
I basically know like almost exactly how
much money they make
and I feel bad that they had bad
management that led them in the
direction of walking away from you know
money that could that was very very
meaningful for an opportunity that
realistically has not panned out yet and
well I mean yeah I mean do you think um
there would ever be
an opportunity for you guys to do a
reunion show
or go on each other's Platforms in the
future is that out of the realm of
possibility
for me I'm looking towards the future
so is it possible I guess anything is
possible but
I just got a lot of good things going
for me right now I'm really focused on
and I don't really feel the need to sort
of go back in time you know
and obviously you know shout out to
Brick baby brick babies break baby
amazing why be better and break baby
better be be better